ستره وبنطال وحذاء باللون الزيتي اختصرت
اطلاله الرئيس الاوكراني في جميع لقاءاته
بزعماء دول العالم فلماذا لا يرتدي البدله
الرسميه حقيقه الامر ان ملابس الينسكي في
القمه العربيه وقمه مجموعه السبع وجميع
الاجتماعات قبلها تحمل دلالات عميقه فمنذ
بدء حرب دولته مع روسيا عام 2022 خلع
الممثل الكوميدي السابق بدلته وارتدى
ملابس اشبه ما تكون بالزي العسكريه للجنود
في اشاره لتضامنه معهم البعض شبه ما فعله
زيلينسكي برئيس الوزراء البريطاني السابق
ونستن حينما اعتمد اطلاله صفاره الانذار
اثناء الحرب العالميه الثانيه تضامنا مع
مواطني المملكه المتحده الذين شاعت بينهم
هذه البدله وقت حدوث الغارات الجويه
لسهوله ارتدائها فوق ملابس النوم والهروب
للملاج